[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're here to talk
about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight
two five five two two five gabe starts
off this hour in minneapolis hi gabe
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for having me i appreciate you
taking my call my pleasure sir what's up
yeah so i had a question about uh saving
in order to maintain a debt-free
lifestyle so
obviously you've got an emergency fund
saving 15 percent
uh towards retirement but obviously you
know
with uh you know things that happen in
life you've got
you know a new car that will come up
eventually there could be
you know new tires or a house uh upgrade
or something like that do you guys
recommend a specific amount of uh like a
percentage of my monthly income that i
should be
saving towards those kinds of things in
life so that i don't have to touch my
emergency fund so additional cash
reserves beyond that
no uh what i do recommend setting some
goals
periodically on those different things
now tires
should be in your monthly budget that
would be called car repairs
okay but saving up to buy another car
what we would do is just be kind of
watching our car and saying okay
three years from now i want to buy a car
four years from now i want to buy a car
which car do i want to buy and you put
that amount on it and then you start
saving that amount per month
out of your budget and that of course
would lower the amount that makes it all
the way through to baby step six
so it would reduce how much you're
paying down on your house in order to
save up to buy the car
um honestly what happens in most
people's lives
is um that most things with the
exception of something like moving up in
a house which is a substantial thing
but even a car something as expensive as
a car
uh it's done in 12 to 24 months
and so from the time you from the time
you look and say i need that
because it doesn't sneak up on you that
you need a new car it doesn't
and if you want to buy a boat it doesn't
sneak up on you that you want to buy a
boat you're going to save up and pay
cash for a boat
if you want to buy a lawn tractor a
couch
a stereo system for the house i don't
know whatever it is you're doing right
it's not gonna sneak up on you
okay that's how much it is and i'm gonna
it's gonna take me x number of months
at y number of dollars per month and i
just put it in the budget
for that period of time and those are
just individual goal
lines because the problem with having
just a general
quote savings account that does not have
a mission
attached to it it tends to get blown
okay it leaves you with that feeling of
out of control like i screwed up with my
money again
because you're just looking over there
and you're going look we've just got a
pile of money we ought to spend it on
something
and and so suddenly you impulse
something then that's
rather large because you had that now
you know you call a slush fund or
whatever you want to call it above your
emergency fund if you want to do that
that's okay
but you know you're saying intentionally
i'm going to have this extra amount of
money that's just for
random things i just wanted this bizarre
wonderful expensive trip
i just want to do this i want to buy a
boat i want to buy a that's the second
time i bought a boat this conversation
but whatever i mean you know
that kind of a thing and so
uh but that that i that's the way we do
it at our house so we don't
we don't sit down and say uh a
set percentage we just say we're gonna
buy a car so we gotta save up and pay
for it
brian is with us brian's in new york
city hi brian welcome to the day to the
ramsey show what's up
uh hey dude how's it going good man how
can i help
all right so pretty much uh i'm calling
because
i plan on becoming a barber but when
you become a barber a lot of the times
barbers tend to be
self-employed and i want to know how i
should go about
handling finances and stuff because
when they get their money they handle
their taxes and i've had a w-2 the
entire time i've worked so i don't know
if you guys recommend anything or what
you know i just want to play it safe and
make sure that my new career goes
smoothly good for you well i think the
key you said you're self-employed and
we teach small business people and
leaders all over america
through entree leadership how to run and
handle a business so the basics for you
would be you need to treat this like you
own your own business because you do not
only technically but actually
and so what it amounts to is then you
need to open a separate checking account
for your business all of the revenue
that you create in your business should
only go
in that checking account first
nothing should come out of that checking
account
no checks should be written no debit
card usage for anything
except business expenses
and so you you know every day you'd have
your collections on uh the hair that you
cut
and you make your deposits uh into the
bank
okay and all of your money goes into the
bank uh into that
checking account and then any expenses
you have which would be
uh what clippers scissors equipment
cleaning gear whatever rent on the chair
you write a check out of that business
account now the definition in business
of profit
is revenue minus expenses
okay and so what is happening is your
checking account becomes
if you're using it the way i'm teaching
you what's called cash basis accounting
meaning
you've done you've got an accounting
you've got a profit and loss statement
because there's
all your revenues there and all your
expenses are there
and what's left in the account by
definition is profit do you understand
yes next step then is you open up a
separate
savings account for taxes
when you take money out of your business
and you bring it home you need to set
aside
a fourth of it over into taxes so i'm
gonna pull a thousand dollars out of
this account
i'm putting 250 in the tax account and
i'm putting 750
in my personal checking to buy groceries
and exist with okay
okay then once a quarter you're supposed
to file quarterly
estimates on your taxes you can see one
of our tax elps for help getting that
set up but it's very easy to do
it's you pi you're supposed to file an
estimate of your taxes based on an
estimate of your profits
so the last three months how much
revenue minus how much expenses did you
have what is your profit
and then you're going to have to file
out fill out a tax form on that and
send in a tax payment guess what you've
got the money to do that because we just
set 25
over into that savings account
okay okay thank you this is all really
helpful i'm 19. so
you just end up with holding on yourself
is what you're doing
now that last step of the taxes is vital
because people screw up with that doing
the type of thing you're doing more
often than almost
anything else and it drives them out of
the business because they say oh i'll
catch up with my taxes towards the end
of the year
and they don't file their quarterlies
they get penalized and then they don't
have the money to file their taxes later
and they end up in in debt to the irs
which is sometimes known as the kgb
so you do not want to owe them money
this is not a place you want to be in
your life
you want to make money pay your taxes
live off the profits
and enjoy this new career of yours
so hold on i'll send you a copy of the
book entree leadership which is
all about starting running a business
and kelly will help you get one of those
the number one new york times bestseller
by the way hang on appreciate you
hanging out with us
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm dave
ramsey your host open phones at
825-5225
if you're struggling with money
it's easy to tell yourself i'll deal
with it later i'll start fresh maybe at
the new year
because that stress can just make you go
into denial mode that fear i don't want
to face it
i know i've been there i know exactly
how it feels
here's the thing it's going to catch up
she might as well deal with it the
sooner you
start the sooner you're free
so decide right now this is the last
month
i'm ever gonna worry about money if you
make that decision we want to help
and that's why for this month only we're
knocking 30
off a 12-month subscription
a 12-month membership to our most
impactful and life-changing products
financial peace university is a part of
ramsey plus
you want to go through the class that
almost 10 million people now have been
through
and have had unbelievable results
that's part of ramsey plus you want to
plug into the world's best budgeting app
the premium version of our
budgeting tool every dollar connects to
your bank and it runs right with your
debit card and
boom you've got a system now you've got
a way of working the plan
we're going to make it a lot easier it's
all 30 off only 99
right now so and you can get a free
trial
to ramsey plus and check out all of this
so how do you get the free trial you
text trial 233 789
text trial two three three seven
eight nine brandon's with us in denver
hi brandon welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for having me on my
pleasure how can i help
all right so my wife and i we're 29
years old
i'm a transitioning service member after
about eight years in the service
we're actually really excited to get
back to knock to the knoxville area
and start putting down some roots after
moving around so much in the military
we've got no debt and we have about
three hundred thousand dollars
saved in the bank wow um we've got 23
000 accessible penalty free and a roth
ira
in like an absolute emergency situation
right
so my question is we're looking to move
back to knoxville
around january should we throw
all the money on a modest house and just
be done with baby step six
um unleash our income to to save and
give and and
and uh invest now
or should we um buy kind of like more of
like our forever home
get a small mortgage for something like
that something we see ourselves in
for a much longer time maybe in a better
school zone
or should we do something completely
different
okay well thank you for your service
what uh what are you gonna be doing for
a living
so i am actually looking to get into
project management
um that or something in supply chain
management that was my uh my undergrad
at ut thank you for your uh for your
guest speaking at my
graduation in 2014. i appreciate that
wow
that's fun yeah so you you were a supply
chain logistics guy coming out and then
huh wow
cool that's right that's fun well um
supply chain is a great field you should
be able to land something in knoxville
there's a lot of distribution in that
area
as a matter of fact a uh another young
man that walked across the stage the
same time you did as a
friend of my sons who walked across the
stage
when you did as well uh the exact same
stage at the exact same graduation
ceremony and he is working
in supply chain at a uh a major trucking
outfit there in knoxville he's a friend
of the family that's how i know that so
anyway yeah yeah i think i know who
you're talking about i've got some
friends and friends of
one of your sons yeah daniel yeah so
okay cool
uh well yeah you're gonna land
there um number one i gotta get your
income
before we make a decision but let's make
the assumption for purposes of your
question
that um what would i do if i had a
supply chain job which is probably going
to put you close to 100.
uh give or take and is your are you
married
i am married outside the home so she did
she had a job in i.t
consulting a really good job she's a lot
smarter than me she went to vanderbilt
and uh we actually were able to just
have her
be a full-time mom okay and um
and so she's currently not working okay
that's cool all right so we're dealing
with a hundred thousand dollar income
you're 30 29 30 years old
and we've landed that job if you've done
all of that
uh not counting the roth ira i'm going
to set an emergency fund aside and i'm
going to pay cash for a modest home
now 250 000 house in knoxville tennessee
is not bad that's a nice house
sure it's not bad at all uh and then i'm
going to use your income and just
systematically save and move up and home
uh there's no such thing as a forever
home because your life changes and
nothing
nothing is forever so i mean you have
you have a set of homes when you're
raising kids when you're empty nesters
when your grandparents and
you know we've we've moved uh several
times in our life
and really none of them have ended up
being a forever home because your life
just changes you go through seasons
in your life so but it but it's you know
you might be in this home we're talking
about five years rather than 10 though
and uh you're going to use that five
years with no house payments to save up
like crazy
pay cash for the next house and move up
meantime you're going to become very
wealthy
and you've done a great job you've set
yourself in position to do that
you can go the other route and take out
a mortgage and begin to pay that down
and be back at baby steps four five and
six if you want
it's not the end of the world as long as
the mortgage is no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
you're not violating what we teach uh
but man
if i was 30 years old and 100 debt free
it'd be hard to talk me into going into
a debt again house and everything i'd be
wanting to use that house payment
two thousand three thousand bucks a
month and build build some wealth and
uh be generous and move up in house with
all of that
preston's with us in arizona hi preston
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
i'm just going to preface this by coming
out with my dad i'm about 250 thousand
dollars in debt right now
um i did not find you until after i
applied and got into medical school
and then it kind of turned into i can't
pay for this unless i
take out student loan um and so
right now my wife is pregnant with our
first little baby boy we're super
excited
um but she's doing november
um so i have a question about what to do
leading up to that right now that you
know i'm living off of student loans and
my wife's
income wow well congratulations on the
baby
so uh when will you uh when will you
graduate
next year i should be starting my
residency in 2023
and that's the other thing i'm thinking
about doing pediatrics right because
that's a three-year residency i can go
right into the work field after i
make about 200 000 a year kind of tackle
this debt as quickly as possible but if
i put another two
years into it i can make four hundred
thousand dollars
um doing pediatric emergency medicine
so that's the other thing i'm looking
into but i should
start my residency with an income in
2023
okay and so what does your wife make
my wife makes about 58 000 a year and
you guys are
living on that and you're paying for
school with student loans
right yeah that's the best way to put it
and the thing
no one tells you about med school is how
expensive it is outside of just tuition
books question banks you know
yeah everything
okay um
well uh mathematically she's going back
to work after the baby comes
yes absolutely absolutely we we know
that for sure
okay know your student loans are um
on hold until you graduate and then you
pound them with your doc income
and clean up the mess you made when you
get out right you just live on
continue to live on her income and put
your whole income towards
the student loans when you do come out
your residency income first and then
later your full income until you've
cleaned up the mess
uh but uh you know and i think you take
her income
now and pile up as much as we can to the
side to cover for the issues with the
baby and
the expenses associated with the baby
coming and with her being off work i
don't know whether she's got paid
maternity leave or how long
she's got paid maternity leave um and
you know that's where you got to land is
we got to take care of this but just
pretend like your household income's 60
000 cause it is
and what are we gonna do maybe it's on
the way we're gonna get ready for baby
and get ready for that time off and then
she's gonna go back to work as soon as
possible
before the maternity leave runs out for
sure
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show big week around here at
ramsey we launched a new podcast on
monday called the fine
print which is what you're supposed to
read before you get in trouble right
well we get read it for you and george
campbell and the team at ramsey networks
have put together wonderful documentary
style investigative reporting and
there's 10 episodes on the fine print
the first two launched on monday
and it landed as number one in the
business section of itunes
so a huge launch on that podcast very
well received
lots of you have downloaded it and
listened to it we also
launched ken coleman's new book on
pre-sale
it is uh from paycheck to purpose
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing
work you love finding where you are and
who you are
getting plugged in and uh man it's
pretty incredible the sales on it have
been awesome
it actually comes out in november and
we're pre-selling it for 20
with about a hundred dollars worth of
extra bonus items while you're at ramsey
solutions.com picking that up
you can get all kinds of things there
going right now there's some free money
giveaways we're giving away 500
cash every week and a grand prize of
three thousand dollars at the end of
august
and uh that's uh no purchase necessary
uh christy wright last week we launched
her new book
uh that comes out in september take back
your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance so the old ramsey
personality's been a little busy lately
getting things out and the team around
here working and man some good good
things coming out of our team right now
on content to help you guys and
to help you transform your lives and
balance your lives and it's a
really really neat place open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five donny
is with us
in dayton ohio hi donnie how are you
i'm great thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um the situation um my wife and i her
uh unfortunately her father passed away
and
he left us a a large sum of inheritance
we have paid off all the bills paid off
all the house
and we have about two hundred 000 left
over and we're not quite sure
what to do with that money wow well good
for you for asking the question
here's the thing money that you do not
give an assignment to so your question
is very wise
money that you do not give an assignment
to leaves and then you wonder where it
went
and so somewhere deep down you knew that
and that's why you're asking this is
very wise
so what i'm going to tell you to do more
than anything is whatever you do with
this money
go ahead and do it on paper on purpose
and make a plan for it just have a
mission for the money
there's three things you ought to do
with money as you build wealth
and as you inherit wealth and in your
case you've inherited wealth
um number one thing you ought and this
is all includes your budget which ought
to have a lot of money in it now too
given you don't have a house payment
right
correct correct so what i
what i want you to do with both things
of money
is to do three things with them and
assign
the dollars to these three things
generosity
be giving money always be giving money
intentionally
saving and investing always be saving
and investing
intentionally and enjoying
you should always be enjoying some of
the money
and so you could take the 200 000 for
instance and say
uh we're going to spend 50 000
and create a memorial for
her father uh by giving money to the
college he went to
and having a scholarship fund i just
made that up i don't care okay
but you're gonna do something that's fun
and it doesn't seem like um
you know it could be ten thousand
dollars it could be five thousand
dollars i don't care it's your money
but i want you to put some amount of
money to go to some kind of generosity
or kinds of generosity same thing with
investing we're gonna take
x number of dollars and we're going to
buy a paid for rental property or we're
going to take x number of dollars we're
going to put it in mutual funds
and then the third thing is is there's a
couple of items that i
always wanted we always wanted and we're
going to buy them
and or do this trip that we've always
wanted to do that makes us smile when we
think about it
and that's called blowing money and
that's okay
but we're not going to blow 199 000 out
of 200 and invest
500 and give 500 obviously that's absurd
okay but guys like you could ask that
kind of question don't do that kind of
stuff anyway
so you're not that guy but uh but
the the point being there's not a set
ratio but when you put it down and you
say
oh man if we blew that much i'd feel
weird about it well then you about
reached your limit on how much you're
gonna
spend on lifestyle but maybe you're
gonna buy a nice car
or maybe you're gonna buy a i don't care
whatever your thingy is that you want to
buy and then you know how much do we
want to invest well we put so much in
investments it doesn't feel like we're
very generous well then you need to back
it down a little bit
so the three things should balance each
other out and and
it should kind of make you uh
i don't know a little bit nervous if
you're
pushing one of those to the edge you'll
kind of know what your values are
especially the two of you talk about it
here be an interesting exercise too for
your marriage and you say okay
we have to write down an amount that
we're going to be generous with
and then tell the other one what it was
and the amount that we're going to be do
all three i'm going to put
x to generosity y to uh investing
and z to lifestyle blowing and each of
you put down a number
that adds up to 200 000 and then compare
what your notes were
and see how close you were to each other
you and your wife
right that'd be a fun game one night you
know so there's that
very fun game yeah and then and but it
gives you it's a good starting place for
the conversation and go
okay why so much on the generosity or
why are you so chinchy you don't want to
give anything away
you know it's a fun it's a good
conversation sharon and i do it a lot
because we get a check from a publisher
or check from this or that and
you know we're already have our
lifestyle covered and so when we get
extra money
in you know half of it goes to taxes and
tithe and then the other half
we have to set aside for generosity and
for
uh in increased even more generosity
than tithe
and uh and we enjoy some of it
um and of course we continue to invest
in
uh for the purposes of more generosity
and the purposes of
more enjoyment uh and for the purposes
of changing our family tree
so there's not an exact right or wrong
formula the thing is you
ought to have an amount a good amount on
each of those three
and it ought to make you feel right when
you look at the number
and your house will be different than
mine on what feels right
dwayne is with us in tampa florida hi
duane welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
a pleasure to talk to you and i
appreciate your advice
um so we have a mortgage right now fha
mortgage that has
mortgage insurance for the life of the
loan and i think it's about a hundred
and
fifty dollars a month or something like
that um we're looking to refinance
um the current rate we have a 3.75
not sure what the new rate would be but
what the the person wanted to do was
roll
our car payment and our highest credit
card
into a cash out refinance of course i
did and
and then we wanted my wife really
doesn't want to do that
good uh doesn't want to pay for that
over the life of the loan so just
really seeking your advice what should
we do as far as refinance or should we
just refinance to get rid of the
mortgage insurance yeah asking a
mortgage person if you need a bigger
mortgage is like
asking a dog if it's hungry because he
gets paid on
he gets paid on the amount of the
mortgage you're right
that's how he gets paid so the
underwriter fee
and that's that's what you know no no
we're going to pay off your other debts
using the debt snowball what's your
household income
um right now about uh
two hundred thousand my wife and myself
excellent
and how much debt do you have this not
mortgage
that is not mortgage probably about
all in all with a couple of student
loans we've done for
the kid probably about 80 or 90 000.
okay you make too much money to have
that debt you need to get that cleaned
up that's just sloppy
right right and that's what you need to
do instead of borrowing your way out
of work for 10 months and she was out of
work for yeah
you make 200 a year you got 80 000 in
debt you don't need to be doing it you
need to clean that up
now and get that mess cleaned up as soon
as you can
and you know you don't need to borrow
your way out of debt
by the way obviously you can't do that
so
people try all the time hang on i'm
going to send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover to show you
exactly how to do what we're talking
about here brother
your new listener this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're here open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
ed is with us in pensacola florida hi ed
how are you
hey dave i'm doing good thank you good i
can't help
my question is about the the last couple
days
the see the center for disease control
you know
uh extending the moratorium on uh
evictions and um i
you know i was listening to the news and
normally the news guy he's
he's pretty good but he was kind of um
inflammatory i guess yesterday evening
or saying that
that this is leading toward the
government uh
trying to seize your property uh
are you any kind of worried about that
no
okay there's too many guns in america
they're not seizing our property it's
okay you're gonna be fine oh
it's not going okay but all right no
we're not that's not going to happen
that's just that's just people carrying
on on the news
um and let me add to that that the cdc
does not have the power
to enforce the moratorium it is a
suggested moratorium there are no
federal laws that allow
uh the federal government to interfere
in individual property rights state by
state
the only thing they can do is go through
any federal programs that are there to
enforce them now they can enforce them
on
federally funded tenants and things like
that but they cannot enforce that so the
cdc
is a suggested moratorium and it's up to
florida as to whether they enforce it or
not as a state
the state of tennessee has not enforced
it we had a short period of time in the
state of tennessee last summer
where the uh the local uh
supreme court made a ruling that there
was a temporary moratorium for two
months
in the at the height of kovid last
summer on
evictions and um i actually had one
eviction on one of our properties
pending during that time i had a [ __ ]
that was beating his wife and she left
and we're trying to throw him out
because obviously we don't do business
with twerps like that
um and we couldn't get him out for that
two months but once the
two-month eviction
uh there was an injunction against
eviction evictions in the state of
tennessee for that period of time
now i do not know state by state who
currently has
an eviction uh moratorium or an eviction
injunction
placed and i i would be shocked to hear
that in
is florida that there is one
but i don't think you've got one in
place there you can check with a local
attorney if you want the does your
evictions and ask
and find out what what's really going on
because it's
what controls property rights is not
federal law
state law and so that's the point of the
discussion so
the cdc does not have the power to do
that under law
and so their moratorium is more of a
suggestion
just like they're suggesting people wear
masks
and we're looking i'm looking in the
lobby at 60 people none of which have a
mask on
so that's how much we care about the cdc
right
so yeah and so that you know it's just
you know it's a matter of we've all kind
of gotten disgusted with these twerps
and they're they're throwing their power
around all over the place and it doesn't
work
now so but they can do a lot of things
locally uh you know if the local
legislature passes it your state
legislature passes it now you've got
property right
issues but for instance the i'll give
you another example ed
the right of imminent domain where where
the government takes
property for the good of the community
for instance a highway is coming through
and they take a piece of your daddy's
farm
or whatever they take that house or
something like that because of the
highway rights
that's imminent domain that is all
state law it is not federal law
so were you to argue with the
municipality that was doing that or the
state that was doing that
you would argue that in state court not
federal court
and so because again all private
property
rights issues are not federal
uh and so that's where uh stuff like
executive orders coming out of dc
uh sometimes don't have any teeth in
them
they're more of a mere suggestion which
is really what the cdc's thing is here
so you look it up i'm not an attorney i
got a whole bunch of real estate though
and i'm zero worried about this
in the state of tennessee now if i lived
in new york city i'd be real worried
about it
because apparently they're taking over
everything up there i don't know what
they're doing
but uh lost their dadgum minds but uh uh
but you know you know all of us living
in these uh
in between states where mostly sanity is
still existing
um you know we're not seeing that kind
of thing and i think you're right i
think your news guy was inflammatory
all right up next is going to be karen
in montgomery alabama hi karen welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i bought a house
probably about at the end of 2015
and when i was still in the military
and since then i have moved
and i have been renting the house out
and it's in pretty bad shape
and i'm trying currently to sell it to
an investor
good um it appears that that may fall
through
and it also appears that my tenants are
moving
that's good news because they'll be out
of the way now you can get it sold
yeah yeah um
so where is the house for a regular home
where's the house
it is it's in augusta georgia okay
all right oh there's nothing wrong with
augusta georgia
uh jump online at dave ramsey
ramseysolutions.com and click
on elp for real estate and find a real
estate agent in that area
and that we recommend contact them and
have them go by and look at it so that
if your deal does fall through you have
a real estate agent that can get it
moved you're probably going to have to
about give it away but you can get rid
of it
yeah i actually already i started by
doing that um
and oh is that who you're doing
um i actually just got a phone call from
an investment company about it
um okay so that kind of
seemed to just work out but um the
realtor said that
because of the condition that it's in it
will not qualify for any type of
mortgage
right so they got to sell it to an
investor right
so i'm just not sure that doesn't matter
what to do because
tell the real estate agent to list it
for investor sale
you don't have the money to fix it up
and you need to unload it
yes what do you think it's worth as
junked out as it is today what's this
investor offering you
um the proposal they offered was
94. okay what do you owe um
i o 85 okay good you're out and if it
was all fixed up it'd be 150 right
yes yeah so somebody'll pay 94 or 85 for
it or whatever they'll take it out take
you
take you out of it which is really all
you want at this point
yes heck with the cheese i just went on
the trap
yeah i just wasn't sure if i should
because
if they move out i don't think that i
can i don't think there's any way that i
can afford
to continue to pay the mortgage well
here's the thing it'll take six to it'll
take six to 12 months to get around to a
foreclosure
okay and so during that time you give
the stupid house away
okay so you know get get that real
estate agent back on the phone tell them
you talked to me and i said list it for
investor money only
a bargain at what is it 65 percent of
value
needs repairs cash only sale
right right and get rid of the stinking
thing
um but you know you know and and you
need to probably go ahead and do that
right now because this investor has not
come through yet
right and if you want to put an
exception in the listing for the
investor that's fine um probably a good
idea
that way if that if he does come to the
table but some of those guys just run
around screwing with stuff and don't
actually ever do deals they just
learn something in a seminar to go tie
people's houses
so you need you need somebody to write a
90 000 check
yes yeah and they're out there and this
real estate market's hotter than a
firecracker kiddo it's a great time to
get out of any kind of property
particularly weird stuff that's messed
up like this one is
so you're in a you're in a good position
but
if that elp that you got a hold of
doesn't know how to do that get to a
different elp
we have more than one in augusta georgia
i know that and get one of them that'll
help you get it listed and get it sold
as is because it's an as is where is
deal
you don't need a home inspection we know
it's busted
we know it doesn't work this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five as we talk to you
about your
dollars and cents common sense for your
dollars and cents
common sense is so rare in america today
that if you have it it's like having a
superpower
lorena is with us in canada hi lorena
how are you i am
awesome how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i have i just finished reading the
total money makeover
and i have a question regarding what i
should pay off
um my only debt other than my
99 000 mortgage is a 5200
line of credit now my question
is do i use my tax-free savings account
which
is sixty seven hundred dollars to pay
that off
or do i increase my bi-weekly line of
credit payment to two hundred dollars
bi-weekly
and get that paid off in a year what do
you make
uh gross or not gross
uh gross is 79 000 and 52 000
after taxes and deductions
so you have a tax-free savings account
are you talking about a retirement
account
uh tax resavence account is the
equivalent of your roth iras
oh you're in canada okay okay
yeah we don't cash out retirement
accounts to pay off
debt unless it is to avoid a bankruptcy
or a foreclosure and you're not facing
either so
what we would tell you to do though is 5
000 worth of debt should not take a year
to pay off making 80
000. i mean y'all do that in like three
months
yeah because if i just tighten up the
old budget here tighten up the old belt
uh get lean down on that budget and
let's let's put about
you know what are we putting five or a
couple grand a month a little less on
that
and you're done and that's tight but you
could you're done in three months that's
what you you know four months max
something like that but it
shouldn't take a year we don't want to
wander out of debt we want to punch it
in the nose as fast as we can
mallory's with us in los angeles hi
mallory how are you
hi i'm doing good thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so my father is dating a woman in
ukraine
who's about half his age they've been
dating three years now
but it's gone to the point that he's
spending his money
recklessly on her and he lost his job
during covid
now he's working as a driver and i'm
just really concerned for his
financial safety he's been um he just
bought her a new car
in ukraine she's been paying for her
rent giving her monthly income
and i need some advice on how to address
the situation and help him because i'm
really concerned at this point
how old is he he's 56
and she's about 32 and you are how old
i'm 25. well i'm with you
i mean this does not sound good how many
times has he actually been
in the presence of this woman i would
say about three times a year
usually they meet abroad on vacation
together but she pays
for that trip obviously himself
um but i i wasn't so concerned about it
first i really thought you know
it's just going to be a short
relationship he's going to
wake up soon but where's your mom
third divorce she's um she's still how
long how long have they been divorced
oh about five years now okay but they're
still good friends
yeah um he's just lonely and got stupid
i think so yeah yeah because you think
you think he's getting conned and so do
i
i mean this is like a mail-order russian
bride stereotype thing or something this
is like something you read about right
only it's really your dad we've gone to
the situation where
it's real in his mind and i don't want
to damage our relationship at this point
so i'm just trying to support him but at
this point now he just bought a new car
and yeah that's danger danger
danger will robin's yeah i mean this is
like signals flares going off everywhere
i'm with you there's all kinds of
signals here this doesn't sound right
um i mean is every woman from the
ukraine evil no that's not what i'm
saying
but there's a classic mail-order brush
and bride
scam that's been going around for a
thousand years you know i mean it's just
it's a classic so um
well here's the problem once someone has
powdered your butt
they don't want your opinion about money
or sex
right so you have powdered butt syndrome
it's hard for parents to listen to their
25 year old kids
even when the parent is going nutty
nutty like your dad is okay
so that's the uphill battle you've got
so in other words if he was doing
cocaine
and you walked in there and and started
you know trying to be his mother
and say you're not doing cocaine anymore
you're killing yourself dad i love you
this is stupid you have to stop he's
probably going to toss you out on your
ear you've got you don't have
position of credibility in his mind to
tell him what to do right
who does pastor brother
uncle friend no everyone in
his life has told him he's making a
mistake and he's just starting to push
them away
which is why i've taken the position of
trying to be supportive
but no it's not well you when you
support stupidity and harmful things
you're causing them to occur
right yeah i mean you don't want him to
be under the illusion you think this is
a good idea
but you don't have to be nasty about it
and and cut off relationship
but um you know so i i don't know i
you know you could talk to a family
therapist and get some input that's
better than mine probably i'm not one
but
um sadly i've ended up working in these
things a bunch of times over the years
as a financial coach and so i end up
right in the middle of it and so i end
up with people like dr john deloney
breathing down my neck telling me what
to say so
um you know it probably what you don't
want to do is sever
the relationship but you have a moral
obligation a love
obligation to your father to give him
the warning
absolutely i want him to be set up if he
chooses
to continue or chooses to separate from
anyone who dares question his his wisdom
then that's just on him you can't make
people do that
but listen i you know i don't even know
you and you called here and i love you
enough to tell you the truth
i'm gonna you know i'm not if you hear
me do it all the time to people right
and it's not for the entertainment value
it's because i want them to go win i'm
not gonna lie i'm not gonna participate
and they're crazy
and so that's what you gotta do you just
gotta sit down and go dad i love you
this is scaring me it's got all kinds of
red flags around it
my spidey sense is going crazy and i i'm
afraid for you dad
i think this is a bad thing but no
matter what you do i'm always going to
be here i'm always going to be your
daughter and i'm always going to love
you but you need to hear from me
that out of love i think you're getting
messed over
and i don't think this is going to end
well and i think you really need to get
this
i think you really really look at this
with a solid set of eyes
a simple conversation in person like
that that's an act of love
is necessary in this situation however
i don't think it's gonna work you're
gonna have to watch him crash and burn
because he's not gonna listen to you but
you are obligated
to tell him
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show no
parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being
unprepared for an emergency but teaching
your teens how to be smart with money
can
be a really big job well we got your
back with our digital
self-study courses for teens
you can rest assured that your teen will
know the right way to handle money
no matter what curveballs life may throw
them down the road and the best part
there's no instructor needed
if your teen has a tablet or a computer
they're all set
text self study to 33 789
and you can learn more about all the
different courses we have for your
middle school or your high school or
either one text
self study 233 7
89 our question of the day comes from a
great american company blinds.com the
number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best
possible deal olivia is in missouri i'm
18 years old i live at home with my
parents who i highly respect
they convinced me to get a credit card
for purchases and to pay it off every
month to build my credit score
not only that but they got rid of their
own debit card because they believe that
credit cards are more protected against
fraud
having listened to your show every day i
disagree with them and i want to get rid
of my credit card
i would like advice on how to get rid of
it without upsetting them
if i do get rid of it how do i buy a
house without a credit score
well i don't i don't know how to control
whether your parents get upset or not
uh one thing that that would involve
would how you be how you approach this
subject
and uh number one are you obligated to
discuss this with them
if you're 18 years old uh if you feel
obligated to discuss this with them
um i mean you can share with them some
of the youtube videos of me talking
about this
the debit card has the exact same fraud
protections
as a credit card does
and so they're wrong i got rid of my
debit card because it doesn't protect
fraud it has the exact
same protections for fraud that a credit
card does exact
the exact same protections under visa or
mastercard products either one
so that's just a complete misnomer in
other words it's false it's alliance
mythology
so they're operating with bad
information
if you were to get rid of the credit
card and get a debit card you are not
exposed
to fraud anymore than they are
now everybody in our world today is
exposed to fraud but
uh you have as visa and mastercard both
have a
zero liability policy for fraud they do
not charge you for fraud
it's that simple period um
now if that upsets them
i i can't control whether your parents
are upset or not just like i can't
control
whether or not they're wrong about
something
so you just need to be kind and
respectful and like you have been it
sounds like you're a respectful young
lady
and you can decide to deal with this
after you move out or you can decide to
deal with it head on while you're there
gently and just go mom dad i've looked
at this and this is what i
understand to be true and i'm sorry but
i think you got some wrong information
and so i'll be getting a debit card and
getting rid of my credit card now as far
as a mortgage goes
here's the the core issue olivia that
you're asking
is the credit score necessary to have a
quality life
that's really what you're asking down in
this question
do we have to worship at the altar of
the great fico because the great fico
is the provider of all good things oh
great fico thank you
we bring you offerings of interest and
payments
so that you raise our score due to our
worship of you
and then you give us more debt
because let's think about this why do we
run a why do we go work on how do you
work on your fico score
how do you work on your credit score
there's only one way to do it borrow
money
100 of the algorithm variables
that fair isaac uses to create your fico
score
have to do with your interaction with
debt so when you quit having any
interaction with debt your fico score
your credit score disappears because it
is just that it is a credit
score a score of you dealing with
credit when you quit dealing with credit
you wouldn't have the score anymore
so mine is zero and i have a pretty good
life
i'm have a very good life but i don't
take any offerings to
the great fico so how do you get
how do you build your credit score you
go into debt
and you pay payments so that your credit
score goes up
so that you can go into debt and pay
payments
so that your credit score goes up so
that you can go into debt
and pay payments so that your credit
score goes up
it sounds like a good plan if you're a
bank
but it doesn't sound like a good plan if
it's you
yeah but i might not be able to rent an
apartment yes you can
check out youtube anthony o'neill's on
there talking about it he's got a
beautiful youtube video on there
and he clearly he calls like 25
different apartment complexes and only
one would not rent to him without a
credit score
he just called up and said hey i'm
moving to nashville can i rent there
yeah what's the deposit uh i don't have
any i don't have a credit score because
i'm just moving on my parents house
every one of them but one would rent to
him so this idea that an apartment won't
rent to you out of credit scores
absolute
hogwash it's a lie
you can't get a mortgage without a
credit score yes you can
it's called manual underwriting call
churchill mortgage
and now you have to have zero credit
score none
and you have to have proof of income and
you have to have a down payment and have
like a job
and stuff which you would like to want
to have anyway to get a mortgage
and so you do not have to build your
credit score to get a mortgage that's a
lie
well you have to have a credit score to
get a car loan maybe but you shouldn't
be getting a car loan if you want to be
rich
you have to have a credit score to hey
dude
listen i haven't had a credit score in
30
years and i'm a multi-millionaire
and one of the reasons i'm a
multi-millionaire is i have not taken it
taken any offerings of interest to the
great fico
i have not participated in buying bank
furniture for the bank
i have not participated in paying lexus
motor credit
chrysler motor credit toyota motor
credit general motors credit
ford motor credit
american distress or discovered bondage
i have not followed any of the stupid
debt tricks
that most americans who are broke and
have no money follow
consequently all the money that we made
the only thing that came out of it was
taxes and i had the rest of it to be
generous with and to build wealth with
and i became wealthy
again many times over
and you can too so this idea that that
you have to build your credit score to
have a quality life in america is
absolutely a lie now what you do have to
do is buy things you can afford
and pay cash for them now olivia you're
just going to be kind to your parents
and respectful to your parents and i
don't know what you'll do you're 18.
you've got time don't worry about it but
if i were you i would get rid of the
debit card get a credit card tell mom
and dad i'm sorry i
i know we don't agree about this i still
love you
but if if you're going to have to manage
every item of my business for me to live
here then that means i can't live here
that means it starts to be time for you
to leave because that's a level of
control
that that's that's not okay now if
they're paying for all your bills then
they get to decide
but they're not paying all your bills so
anyway that that's uh you know that's a
case where the parents are normal
the parents are making a mess the
parents are believing a lie
and now they're infecting their own
children with this crap
ah so maddening
again let me restate 100
of the variables that create the
algorithm
mathematical formula that dictates your
fico score
have to do with you interfacing with
credit
it is not the fico score is not a
measure of how good you're doing with
money
it's not a measure of net worth it's not
a measure of your income
your boss can walk in today and give you
a million dollar of your raise it won't
change your fico score
one ounce because it has nothing to do
with debt
fico scores a hundred percent to do with
debt
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage garrett and christina are
with us hey guys how are you
pretty good how about you dave better
than i deserve where do you all live
uh we're from the state of washington
awesome welcome to nashville
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off uh 125
323 all right and how long did that take
you
about 17 months whoa and your range of
income during that time
uh 170 to 205 000.
awesome what do you guys do for a living
uh i'm a journeyman lineman
and i'm an adult felony probation and
parole officer okay
cool so you guys put in some hours then
oh yeah so uh yeah that journeyman
lineman thing you make some money but
you you're getting after it
yeah 40 hour shifts and 18 hours a day
during storm season
phenomenal phenomenal all right so what
kind of debt was the 125
thousand dollars we had 7 000 on credit
cards 24 000 on vehicles
and 94 000 on our mortgage you paid off
your house
we did looking at weird people yeah
i love it how old are you two uh i'm 26
and she's 23.
wow and i paid for house what's this
house worth uh well with today's market
probably 300 000
at 26 and 23 years old
i love this you guys are amazing
wow okay tell me the story what happened
that got you guys so on beat here and
fired up
well uh it kind of all started i was
just out uh out with my dad he always
listens to am radio i hadn't even heard
about you and uh
your show came on the radio and i've
always kind of believed in the debt-free
lifestyle but
didn't know you existed and uh i just
started listening to your show and
after about two days i listened to the
podcast i went down to the bank that day
paid off my credit cards cut them up and
uh paid my car off too and wow
and uh wait a minute did you talk to
christina about this
we just got married a month ago oh oh
okay
i actually i actually yeah
yeah i actually mentioned to her i'm
like hey i'm doing this dave thing and
next thing i know she's like selling all
sorts of stuff
on craigslist and uh she didn't even
tell me but she started doing it too so
it
was pretty awesome yeah so i paid off my
car before we got married and
all we had left by the time we got
married was the house and i had bought
my house when i was 20
and was able to resell it for a pretty
good profit we just since we decided to
keep his house and uh was able to take
the proceeds from that sale and pay off
our house now
ding ding yeah look at this yeah so you
guys were pretty well in control
i mean you were a little bit normal you
had credit card and car and that kind of
stuff
but you'd also been doing pretty smart
stuff at a young age and like buying
houses and that kind of stuff and so
boom you were able to roll all that
together and create a really great story
yeah yeah for sure yeah well done
i mean you had money in the bank to just
go down and pay the stuff off right yeah
i did i was just kind of i was living i
just didn't have a
purpose behind it and that's one of the
big reasons i started falling is like
you know
lots of little charges you don't realize
how fast they add up
and i just want to make a quick mention
how important the emergency fund is uh
during my journey on this uh i sustained
a back injury at work and i was off work
for three months without pay but i had
the emergency fund and so i
was able to just focus on getting better
and didn't have to worry about money
during that time
wow that's a big deal yeah that's a big
deal so you're okay now
yep healed and back to climbing poles
all right good for you man
good for you so you're making you guys
are making great money between the two
of you you're 23 26 with a paid for
house married a whole month
wow okay so it's not like you had this
long drawn out journey i mean you made
like three moves
here and then knocked it out right uh
and finished it off
in terms of the you know marriage and
everything else so what do you guys tell
think the key to getting out of debt is
uh definitely budgeting
is huge um like i said before i started
uh
following the plan i uh i would you know
look at my bank statement and
it's like i would always tell myself oh
i'll start saving for this when i
make a little more money but uh you know
it's
like you gotta take take charge start
budgeting
and uh your little charges add up more
than you think they do so you gotta live
with a plan
to make a plan yeah i hadn't budgeted
ever
in my life and then started making my
budget and at the time i thought i was
living paycheck to paycheck and i
definitely felt like i got a huge raise
once i started budgeting it was like oh
i'm spending a whole lot in this
category when it should
either be not being spent or be spent
somewhere else and so it was
easy i mean i was only making 50 000 at
the time and paid off my vehicle
very quickly because i was budgeting i
didn't really even realize i had this
extra money sitting in there
have you all had time to even sit down
and do the math that making two hundred
thousand dollars a year at 23 26
how rich you're going to be we just kind
of started our
minds are kind of blown yeah it's
millions and millions and millions of
dollars
if you just pay yourself a house payment
for the rest of your life if that's all
you do it's
that's probably close to 10 million
dollars yeah oh my goodness
our smartmaster bro has been pretty
impressed he definitely had some wide
eyes once we told him the house was paid
off
and he's listening today i think too
that's awesome
yeah yeah he's like oh i wish i could
get every 23 26 year old
office to do this oh my god yeah
because he knows how that compound
interest is going to work for you
compound growth on those mutual funds
and
buying other things and the level of
generosity you're going to be able to
have and the
just the level of choices that you've
got in your life already
yeah you know it's pretty cool you guys
have done an amazing job
who were your biggest cheerleaders i
would definitely say each other you know
uh
we kind of at the start before we were
married you know we kept our finances
separate but we
cheered each other on and she would she
would text me during the day like hey
thinking about going out and getting
lunch at work today and i'd be like well
i'm debt-free just wait till the week
and i'll take you out to dinner
and we just kept each other in check and
yeah
and just having that accountability
partner is huge yeah that's a big both
of our families are pretty supportive
but
we've definitely kind of started making
our own path and a new family legacy
no question about it absolutely
impressive what was the hardest part for
y'all
i'm the spender so for me i was in baby
step two
a lot i mean he was a baby step two for
a day until he paid off his car
and it took me about eight eight months
and so for me it was just not spending
money on like small little things like
my dog i want to go spoil my dog and
go buy our toys all the time or eating
out just the convenience of that
was the difficult part of like okay i
used to be able to or want to do this
all the time and i didn't
i wanted to do it but i knew i didn't
need to do it yeah and so kind of
refocusing and
really imagining what life is going to
be like after
the vehicle was paid off and knowing
that we were getting
married eventually and now we're
actually married was a cool goal of
want to be on the same page when that
does come around now we're here
yeah how's it feel now that you're 100
free
it's amazing i can't even explain in
words it's like
the options in life are endless when you
don't owe anybody anything
yeah house projects are a lot more fun
now too
everything is we just look down and go i
need a little money for that okay let's
put in the budget yeah there's plenty
room
you're gonna you got some big thing
planned to celebrate that you're gonna
do or
bye uh we're coming here wow do our debt
free stream and
uh keep uh we're gonna be building
addition on the house pretty quick so
i'm just saving up to cash blow that
and then find a boat after that yeah
okay
good good well you ought to be that's
very well done you're going to be in
great shape you're
you're already in great shape but you're
going to be in amazing amazing shape
this is a
what a story what a wonderful story very
well done we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story to move on to
baby steps millionaire
everyday millionaire status uh you'll be
there if you're not already pretty quick
and uh man you got a great start 23 26
years old paid for house worth 300
paid for everything wow married a whole
month
wow wow wow wow wow amazing
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give to somebody
because uh you can't help but talk about
this stuff and that'll give them a track
that they can run on and go join you in
this
in this quest and this journey very well
done garrett
and christina olympia washington 125
000 paid off in 17 months
making 170 to 205 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're debt-free
it's hard to explain
how rich they're gonna be
[Laughter]
those two oh man
yeah paid for a 300 000 house at 26
years old
journeyman lineman not 300 000 in
student loan debt
at 26 years old but i have a phd
yeah i think he made the right choice
boys and girls
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show kevin is with us in
spokane washington hi kevin how are you
not bad thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well i've been reviewing the beneficiary
status on some of my
accounts and things hsas and
retirement and so my wife and i have
five kids
and i'm wondering they all ask for a
secondary beneficiary
um at what point does it make more sense
to try and set up a trust
now in the event that it was needed
in the event most my wife and i
something happened to us or
should i just break it out
percentage-wise per kid on the secondary
thing it just seems to get a little
complicated i'm wondering when it would
streamline that
yeah um how old are the kids
they're all uh teenagers on down
so they're young they're minors okay
yeah so what we did
at that age um was we made the secondary
beneficiary
the family trust and the family trust
would be formed
or the children's trust whatever you
want to call it the uh
your last name so and so children's
trust that's formed upon your death
as an action of your will your will says
upon both of you dying that this trust
is formed
for your minor children and uh then you
can put all kinds of things into that
trust right you can dump
okay but that's that the purpose of that
trust is to manage all of the assets
basically for the good of the kids
and uh you know and the trustee of the
trust is
their job is uh to if you do the trust
well is to execute
what the trust says to do they're not
allowed to do anything else with that
money
um typically i want the guardian of the
children to be a different person than
the trust
uh trustee yeah it currently is right
now fraud
and uh then you what we had in our
children's trust again it never
activated because our children grew up
and we did away with that portion of our
estate plan
because now it's just left two adult
kids in a different setting right
uh in a much more complicated state plan
these days but but
point being that once they're all grown
you don't have to do that anymore
so um uh but we left it
uh all assets were to be funneled into
that for the good
of those kids now out of that then we
dictated for instance that a monthly
amount off of the returns of the
investments the money's liquidated put
into investments across four types of
growth stock mutual funds like i teach
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
working with the smart investor pro
that's how ours read
and um the monthly income off of that
up to a certain amount would go to the
guardian
for the care of the children effectively
child support
right um and so we want to make sure
that much money is coming out of the
income any other amount would just
continue to grow the wealth
they can't really touch the money for
anything else except maybe to buy a car
when they turn 16
college education major medical event
if some money was needed because one of
them and that we can use the money for
that
and then as they graduate from college
you can distribute
the money to them uh you can actually
distribute it to them at 18 or 21
either way but um ours was uh
it just when they graduated from college
they got their share of the trust
we didn't man we didn't keep it in the
trust until they were 30 so you can do
that if you want
and give half of it a graduation half of
it at 30 or however you want to dictate
it but that's the kinds of things you
can put into that trust then
but the whole point being we're going to
just throw all the money in a pile
and the income off of that takes care of
those kids
right so on the on all the accounts and
everything you just list the trust as a
secondary beneficiary exactly
and within the will you figure out how
to deal with it all right you don't try
and do that on every account
exactly within the will you you for the
for
and the trust is not even formed until
both of you die
right or unless both of you die and so
that trust that i was mentioning earlier
we detailed it all out but it was never
formed
it ended up going in the trash basket
because our kids are grown now
you know and so our old estate plan is
but is predicated on grown people not
minors that must be taken care of and so
it's a different
process now and so but but you still you
still need to do it you need to get all
laid out in case something happens to
both you and your spouse and
that's a beautiful thing you're doing
right there very very smart
art is with us in baltimore maryland hi
art welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i am interested in your perspective
as a christian businessman and landlord
i have about 50 tenants whose rent i
have not
increased in between two and four years
um i'm contemplating raising their rents
five to eight percent which would still
put them
at uh five to ten percent below the
rents that my new market rate tenants
are coming in
at and i was kind of curious given the
uh last 18 months
whether that was just a tone-deaf move
or whether it made sense so
that's my question for you
i don't know why it is
christian to not charge market value for
rent
why is that more why is that a christian
concern
no i just wasn't saying it was
necessarily christian i was just kind of
curious as to
um whether it was charitable if you will
to keep people's rents a little bit low
because of the
challenges we've had over the last year
and a half yeah um
no i i uh what we have done is we've
been charitable
with people who fell on hard times
sure in individual case-by-case
situations
and some other i've got commercial
property and i've got residential
property
and uh you know we had one guy in
residential that lost his job because of
covet
well we you know we didn't we didn't
come down on him like we would have
uh in another time you know we just said
hey we're going to give you some grace
some mercy and
uh you can't live here two years free
you got to go get a job you got to
because you got to pay rent somewhere
right but we're not going to just you
know we're going to give you a little
wiggle room here and then
you know the back rent that you can't
pay right now we'll work it out you can
pay it a little a little bit at a time
and catch up right
and so we did that we actually did that
with uh we have a
a a a workout facility a gym in one of
our commercial properties obviously it
was shut down
and the guy's a small business guy and
so we just said
okay you know we're not gonna
we're just gonna let the rent pile up
and you can catch up later and we'll
work out a catch-up schedule
we didn't forgive it but we just didn't
we just didn't muscle him you know
and so uh and that was just an act of uh
compassion it's also not a bad
business move because by the way if you
throw them out you got to put somebody
else in there in the middle of this
environment so
uh but i keep we keep our rents at
market across the board
and then on a case-by-case basis where
we run into a situation whether it's
covid related or
just an individual situation we had a
tenant one time who
um the dad was the sole provider and uh
he got terminal cancer
you know so uh and i'm not the kind of
guy puts that family
in the street right yeah i've been there
as well
so i mean you know you you work with
them and uh
you know i don't i don't want to be
played and i don't want to be conned
but uh uh and sometimes people will try
that stuff you probably experience that
as well but on the other hand
you know the good news is i don't have
any debt on this so i don't have to
collect the rent to eat
and because i'm collecting market rent
on everything else it gives me lots of
margin to be able to be merciful over
here
on the other side so we keep all of our
properties at market as best we can
as close as we can within reason we
don't overcharge an undercharge
it's not greed driven it's just a matter
of being a good
steward a good manager of the assets
that god has given us to
manage and amongst that is mercy and
charity
on individual case-by-case basis but i
don't think it's charity to just say
overall i don't charge as much
and somehow lump that under our faith
issue that's not
that's just not that's i i don't agree
with that hey thank you for the call
it's a good discussion i appreciate you
bringing it up
you're a good person obviously a great
man thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money by the way it's always
good to remember
money is not the root of all evil
the love of money is the root of all
evil
money just buys clothes for your kids
and
keeps the lights on and puts food on
your table
pays the rent money's not good or bad
but when you place it in the hands of a
human oh my gosh
get to see how that human is wired don't
you
this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsey advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it's a free call
anywhere in north america if you want to
talk about your life or your money we're
here for you
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five pat is in modesto
california hi pat welcome to the ramsey
show
actually it's riverbank california but
it's next door to modesto does that
count
it does i'll go with that how can we
help
okay i got noticed from my long-term
insurance that their uh
premiums are going up from 1056 annually
to about 4 000 in over the next few
years
also the notice gave me like a number of
options and
i bought a plan years ago when i was
managing my dad's affairs
and he had a plan and it was you know it
seemed like
a good idea to me at the time and i also
went on your website
and did the insurance survey and and
found out that you do indeed recommend
long-term insurance but
i don't have kids if i burn through my
whole estate
when i go to a rest home who cares and
then you go on nutty nutty
what so i need some ideas why i should
keep an insurance plan now the other
thing with this is just gen worth my
plan that i have
and it's and they also included in the
information that
um they have a c plus plus
uh financial strength and they have
manageable a
marginal ability to meet its ongoing
insurance
obligations and so it's like
okay how old are you i'm 67
how much money do you have
um i have 600 000 in my uh retirement
i have a 42 000 investment that i have
earmarked for
a vehicle if my my husband's currently
in the rest home
he's been there for about a year and
then if my miracle he gets better and
comes home i will need a vehicle for him
and um so that's your mark for that and
then i got about 38 000 in savings
the house is worth about 250.
[Music]
how's your husband's health
not good i'm sorry he's improved a
little bit over the last
month so it's kind of like i'm in limbo
i don't know
sure if he's gonna come home or not okay
well here here's the thing um
the average time spent nationally in a
nursing home is 2.4 years
the average cost is a little under a
hundred thousand a year
okay so that means i know that i know
that well
yeah and and so he was i was not able to
buy a policy for him
right because even 20 years ago he had
rheumatoid arthritis and that excluded
him from coverage so you're paying him
you're paying for this no he's on
medical
oh okay i'm medical my income is low and
low enough my monthly income is low
enough to work
my sure cost is only 145 dollars so okay
quality care is fine
party the quality of care is fine in
that program then i'm assuming
yes yes he is in a good place yes good
all right good well i just want to make
sure he's taken care of and you're taken
care of because that's what the whole
discussion is really about right
so if you didn't go on medi-cal
but it sounds like you could as well
possibly go on that
if that something happened that you need
a nursing home but let's just pretend
worst case scenario you had to fund
yours and it took two and a half and the
average stay was two and a half years
well if you went twice the average oh
almost three times the average
six years at a hundred thousand you
would burn through your money
right right the likelihood statistically
of you doing that
is close to zero statistically
you see what i'm saying because i mean
the chance you're doing three times the
average
stay would be highly unusual
um i mean it had to be an unusual uh
issue and of course the other options
you've got
with with six hundred thousand dollars
in your hand you could do in-home care
you could do a lot of other things
so you can afford to drop this and to
self-insure
given given those numbers okay um
70 of claims right now on
long-term care insurance are for in-home
care
only 15 of the claims are nursing home
care
now that's not medi-cal i'm talking
about private like your gen
like your gen co proper or your gen
worth deal okay
and so this is what the typical
typical thing is and so um
the average uh you know just lots and
lots of averages you can look at on this
but
the um
you know you guys are living out a
fairly normal situation
typically 75 of the ladies outlive their
husbands
and so dad goes into the nursing home
cracks and scrambles a nest egg
if he doesn't have long-term care
insurance or in this case medi-cal right
so i take it that's a california program
that you're under i'm not
i'm not familiar with it but that right
it's it's
uh california's version of medicaid
right okay
and um and and some places the
quality of care on a medicaid nursing
home is
substantially lower and so other states
you might not want to do that but
you in your case you found a way that
are you your situation is that
he's getting quality care there and
likely you would too
um you know and so you might not even
burn through the money even then
but so do you take the chance uh if i'm
in your shoes i probably do given the
numbers i just gave you
if you told me you had a hundred
thousand dollars to your name i'd tell
you get a policy
to make sure that you had coverage and
to make sure you had care
which is important but i mean i don't
think the chances of you burning through
600 grand are very high
to start with we're probably not going
to touch it at all with medi-cal
and even if we did you got to go three
times
the national average in your nursing
home stay which would be very unusual i
mean you'd have a cognitive thing
where your body didn't deteriorate
that's the type of a thing where you
would stay 10 years
you know and um but that's the only
i mean anything where your body
deteriorates
not your mind you know you're not going
to make it 10 years
that that's just i'm just that's kind of
cold but that's how we all face we're
all we're all not gonna make it so
that that's that's how we have to have
these discussions because this is about
probabilities
and statistics and trying to gauge that
into common sense with our personal
lives and where we stand
you know and so if i woke up in your
shoes knowing what i just laid out here
between medi-cal and 600 grand
i'm not re-upping if i'm in your shoes
i'm gonna self-insure through this issue
does that make sense to you okay it does
it does and it was a consideration
because i could say so if so what if
something happened and i burned through
all the money and i had to go on medical
who cares
yeah well i mean you know i don't even
have time i don't have kids
i don't have anybody depending on or
standing at the door waiting for my
house or my money
yeah that's exactly right and that's why
you did this is to take care of you
that's why you have 600 grants why you
save money is for your
so that you would have options and care
and so on
it's very important good discussion
thanks for joining us
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all the research that we have seen in
the last 30 years
on diy investing do-it-yourself
investing
tells us what we already knew
that when 2020 hit people made a lot of
mistakes
see here's the thing you need some
investment professionals in your corner
they don't need to tell you what to do
but they're there to teach you
and sometimes to talk you off the ledge
when you go into panic mode
you absolutely absolutely need someone
in your life
hey i'm a do-it-yourselfer i fix some
stuff myself but i don't pull my own
teeth
and i don't even work on my own cars
anymore
there's i don't even know what's under
that hood it looks like a big battery to
me but it's not
because i don't have one of those cars
so here the problem is you get investing
in the wrong things when you don't have
help you get caught up in trends you
make rookie mistakes
you make emotional decisions that are
stupid
and that happens to everybody unless
they've got someone in their corner and
that person can say listen calm down
breathe
ride the roller coaster to the end of
the ride
let 2020 be your wake-up call never
again let your retirement be at the
mercy
of a global crisis go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and create a rock solid
investing plan today ramsey solutions
dot com slash
smart vester lucian is with us
in akron ohio hi lucian how are you
i'm great how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i'll give you a little bit of
context and then i'll shoot the question
out there
i've been i'm a small business owner and
been grinding it pretty hard for about a
decade
and going into it the business was a
vehicle for me to get
to financial independence i wanted to
have assets that
kicked off passive income greater than
my my active expenses and uh
so i'm about 10 years in and i owe 150
000 on my home mortgage
and that's my last last debt that i have
and it's hanging over my head and
i'm getting kind of weary in the
business and
um i've got the cash in my business to
to basically write a check and pay off
the home mortgage and i'm tempted to do
that and i want to do that
but i have not yet this year
invested 15 and i have not yet
this year put away i've got three kids
so i haven't put away i've been putting
away 2 000 a year per kid i haven't done
that yet
so i guess my question is is it wrong to
just get this home mortgage debt off my
books and off my
conscience and just be done with it
uh or is that the bad thing to do or
should i
you know just stay the course and keep
keep going ahead
and and not pay that off all at once and
get that paid off down the line
what were your problems will your
profits be for uh 2021
what will my business profits be for
2021
um probably gross income somewhere
around
200 hundred and ten thousand twenty
thousand something like that
so why could you not put fifteen percent
and your kids college
funding out of that
uh so i probably could i i could
probably have the ability to do
it right now and then no i'm just saying
i'm just saying it's not an either or
so now the second question is you got
150 000
in your business is that what you told
me yes sir
and and the mortgage balance is what
150.
i got about 160 in the business the
mortgage balance was 150.
it sounds like you're going to have zero
retained earnings or close
when we do this no money left in the
business
yeah i've got i've got i've got income
coming in about
maybe 30 000 in the next 30 days
yeah that's part of your 200 000 income
though right
it is yeah okay
i don't want you to leave the business
so skinny that that it collapses because
we left the cash poor
i don't i don't know what your cash
needs are around this business or cash
fluctuation
um either you have a very very high risk
tolerance and
that you you don't mind rolling the dice
on stuff and it doesn't you don't even
flinch when you do it
or your business does not have much cash
need
uh both i'm a real estate sales person
oh okay okay yeah you don't have much
cash need
so 10 000 with 30 000 coming in wouldn't
kill you
all right
well we've got reserves tucked away for
personal you know
yeah i know but i'm just saying i didn't
know whether you're running employees or
what you had you know i don't know what
kind of payroll you're running and
i don't i don't want a hiccup to come in
and take you guys out because we used
all your cash
because you didn't keep a liquidity
position and you need to do that from a
business perspective but yours is a
a little different model so um yeah i'm
probably paying off the house awesome
all right now and as a part of that i'm
also going to commit to
using my income this year to going ahead
and funding my 15
and finding my kids college but we may
do that a little bit later in the year
but i think i mean it's only uh 30
what's 60 grand or 30 grand
that's all you need uh to do that and
and you know and let's then let's also
rebuild and keep some cash in your
business
um it doesn't sound like it's necessary
to keep 150 000 in your business
and so just um you know keep pushing
through but
congratulations you're doing a great
great job
but make sure i'll just go ahead and
play through with it because baby steps
four and five
generally should be cash flowed out of
your budget
not out of lump sum cash and
you know then baby step six is any cash
we come into past
those things in our budget or in your
case we're taking some of your retained
earnings in your business and you're
gonna pay off the house
that's more lump sum stuff at baby step
six
matt is with us in spokane washington hi
matt welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you great what's up
uh well i'm hoping that you can help me
out with a
retirement ceremony my wife and i are
working on we're both 51 years old
we have four kids three of which are
going to be in college this year
and i have one with a senior in high
school
i have a previous retirement from the
military
so and i'm still i'm working a part-time
job now my wife is fully employed
um we're doing all the right steps i've
listened to you for years and years i've
never actually read your books
so i don't exactly know all the steps
and what um
whatnot but i think we've got a pretty
good handle on it
we'd like to retire within the next year
or two for good
and just travel and live off of what
we've invested and what we've saved
um my question is the only debt we have
right now
is our mortgage now we owe 212
000 on that i have the money
in one of my mutual funds and investment
accounts that i could cash out
and pay that off that account that i
would
use to do that with though was the one
that i was primarily going to live off
if we retired early until i turned 59
and a half that i can tap into my
laptop layers and my traditional so
i also have you know we have money in
the bank and whatnot so
i'm just i think i already know the
answers but
um i just wondered if that would be a
smart move to go ahead and cash out that
account
what's your what's your uh total mistake
counting retirement and everything
um well let's see with in the iras we
have about 600 000
i've got 70 000 in the bank and um
there's two hundred and thirty thousand
in that account i'm talking about
cashing out
and then uh you know i got some other
missing accounts that we could tap into
thirty five thousand so we're looking
total
you know total investments was like 1.2
million
just locked up until i'm 59 and a half
right
so if we pay off the mortgage with this
how do you travel how do you eat
well until 59. i say we're talking about
retiring so i still have a military
income and we're both still employed
yeah but i'm saying if you retire if you
pay off the mortgage with this
and you retire what's your military
income
[Music]
uh it's about 3 000 a month okay somehow
i don't think you're living on that
so how are you going to live no how are
you going to live and travel
well we're looking at using that um the
other 200 000 that we have invested
what not oh i thought you had only 200
in one place so you've got 400 that's
non-retirement
yeah we have so okay between ras and
traditionals i have 600 thousand dollars
in those yeah but you can't touch the
roth iras or retirement until you're 6
59 and a half you already brought that
up so yeah i'm paying off the mortgage
definitely paying off the mortgage in
this case
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show
jason and stephanie are with us in
austin texas it says on my screen you
guys are
debt free congratulations thank you
thanks dave way to go how much have you
paid off
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
awesome how long did this take
it took 13 years we had a few setbacks
but we kept at it and did it okay and
your range of income during that time
uh 70 000 and now 140
000 cool what do y'all do for a living
i am a construction engineering
inspector
and i'm a licensed professional
counselor excellent
what kind of debt was the 150 000
it was uh vehicle debt credit cards and
student
loans wow all right well tell me the
story what happened 13 years ago and
what does this journey look like well i
was feeling sick to my stomach every
time i was writing those checks every
month
for all those credit cards and all that
debt and a class was offered at our
church
and i'm so grateful that we went and and
we
hopped in right away i was a little
quicker than jason
he hopped on a little bit after me i'm
the nerd he's the free spirit
and uh and we started from there
very cool and so you've been on a
13-year journey since then
have we uh we had a few setbacks jason
had an injury at work and then our
youngest son
was diagnosed with brain cancer at age
two and so that created a whole other
uh situation that we had to to work
through
um and uh set us back a little bit and
we just kept
powering ahead yeah a lot of things that
were more important than getting out of
debt you got to take care of that baby
that's right
good yes and that um
you know cancer is all-consuming cancer
in a child is
all consuming yeah
wow you guys that's amazing so how's he
doing
he's doing great he is seven years
cancer-free this november so it's
amazing
all right very good so you guys just
kept in spite of uh
these overwhelming medical situations
just kept
peck peck pecking away and finally
chipped your way all the way through
we did yes that is an amazing amount of
perseverance
thank you 13 years wow
most people can't most people can't
watch 13 minutes of a television show
without changing the channel
i know we we call us we call ourselves
we're like
old school dave fans
back before it was easy
yes exactly oh my gosh
well you did you powered your way
through which makes it all more sweeter
doesn't it yes it does indeed yeah how
does it feel to be free
it feels amazing i think sometimes we
sort of pinch ourselves because it
doesn't seem
real yet because it's been such a long
time coming
and i'll listen a lot to your show
and it is it's it doesn't seem real yet
because like when people do the debt
free scream it's like i'm gonna be there
one day i'm gonna be there
and now i'm here and it's like i mean
i'm just i'm just overwhelmed
with with uh joy and a huge
huge weight has been lifted little
surreal then huh
yes yeah wow wow crazy
amazing wow well well done well done you
guys
very very well done what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
that's the key we started giving our
church did a challenge a tithing
challenge and
our pastor told us if uh if if we didn't
didn't uh reap the reward and the
blessing of
tithing which doesn't mean money it
comes in many different ways that he
would give us our money back and we've
never had to ask for it back for 13
years
that's the ticket right there we have
faithfully tied this entire time and we
do not
not regret it one bit that's a
money-back guarantee you never have to
write the check for
there that's a good one i love that
well done you guys very very well done
very well done you guys are heroes for
continuing to push through on this
absolutely amazing very well done so
proud of you
excellent thank you we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
and um uh you know
definitely go on and change your whole
family tree and an extra copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away get someone else's journey started
because i'm sure folks have been looking
over your shoulder and watching you as
long as you've been doing this
and so just very very powerful on your
part very well done so proud of you
oh thank you so much jason and stephanie
austin texas a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars paid off in
13 years a couple of medical events
during that time to say the least
making 70 up to 140. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that is how it's done oh my goodness
how fabulous is that very very cool
john is with us john is in indianapolis
hi john how are you
hi dave doing great i can't believe i'm
talking to you well i'm glad to talk to
you sir how can i help
well my wife and i are in baby step two
and we anticipate uh
turning our retirement contributions
back on january 1
2024. however her employer is giving her
a one-time choice that we have to decide
on right
now option one is she can maintain the
401k
match which they they throw in three and
a half percent and
maintain her portable pension account
100 provided by the company
option two is she forces the pension uh
less the invested balance i'm sorry
option two is what
you cut out when you said option two
option two is what
option two is um she no longer has the
pension option
but her 401k match goes up to eight
percent
so we're wondering if it's what your
wisdom is as far as do we keep the three
and a half percent match
and and the company pension which by the
way they they throw in five percent of
her gross
per year so the face value of option one
is about eight and a half percent
of her gross or option two with a higher
401k
match which has a face value of eight
percent and more options with
um investments but uh but no pension
what is uh that the uh yeah uh
the um the pension yeah the pension
account compounds at about four percent
a year so i mean
maybe keeps up with inflation but no no
significant growth it's more
risk-free yeah
i mean the the only way to do this
properly is to get all the way down in
the numbers which we can't do on a radio
call if you sit down with a smart vester
pro they can help you do that
but there's a couple i i think where
you're going to land
i'm very sure where you're going to land
is option two
at the end of the story and the reason
is that
when you die one hundred percent of that
money is yours
when you die and with option one the
pension dies with you
if there's a survivor benefit it dies
with the second person to die but it
eventually dies
the uh and so all of the other money is
going into a
you know the extra five percent in
option two is going
into a good investment an investment
that works
better than the pension works and
doesn't disappear when upon death and so
those two things
generally will have you pick all things
being equal
the 401 k my guess is
that they have also done the numbers
because most companies have moved away
from pensions
and it sounds like this company's trying
to move away from pensions
and so they're being generous with
option two to get you to do it
because most companies hate these things
they're a pain in the butt to deal with
and they don't perform that well so no
one's really winning at the end of the
day on this
so i'm going to tell you i think there's
a 90 probability you're going to land on
option two
but without actually combing through
every piece of the arithmetic i can't be
100
sure on that but i think that's where
you're going to end up for those reasons
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day revelations 3
20 behold i stand at the door and knock
if anyone hears my voice and opens the
door
i will come into him and dine with him
and he with me elizabeth elliott said
when you don't know what to do next just
do the thing
in front of you wow bill is with us
bills in lansing hi bill welcome to the
ramsay show
hey what's up dave thanks for your time
my pleasure how can i help
i have a question for you so i am a
massage therapist
and i left my job at the end of april
it just wasn't a there wasn't a lot of
healthy leadership going on there
and some other things that made me leave
and go on my own
yeah a lot happier than i did now but my
question is
i had a simple ira that my employer
provided
and i only have about the balance of it
right now is seventeen hundred dollars
so i'm calling to see i know typically
we don't talk about like you know
cashing out retirements and stuff like
that
but i'm wondering if i should convert
that over into a traditional
or if i should cash it out and then put
it into my existing loss
as that lump sum minus the taxes that i
would owe on it
well you can roll it to a traditional
and not pay any taxes on it
uh you can roll it to a traditional and
then
convert it to a roth and pay the taxes
on it or you can cash it out
those are really your three options you
can't really put it
into another roth you got but you just
creates its own
is what it is each account is like
sorry that's okay each account is just
its own that's all it is
so if you cash it out i mean really the
truth is
that uh on 1700 bucks it's not going to
change your life no matter what you do
with it
right absolutely i just wanted to make
sure that it wasn't anything that i was
missing now
and so that's just the you know you
could go any direction you want to go
you're going to give the government
a third of it if you cash it out you're
going to give the government a third of
it if you convert it to a roth
or you're going to have to pay the
equivalent of a third of it
if you convert it to a roth so get ready
to write an extra 500
check to the government if you convert
this to a roth wouldn't be a bad idea
it's always a great idea to get as much
as you can in tax-free growth and so
that's probably what i would do with it
is i would just go ahead and roll it to
a roth ira
and pay the taxes they come to as a
result
of that assuming you have the money to
pay 500 bucks
when your tax bill comes to you uh but
it sounds like you're making money as a
massage therapist now maybe you should
be able to do that
randy's with us randy is in tucson hi
randy welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up so my question is my husband
and i owned a commercial cattle ranch
for 10 years and we sold it last year
with the profits of the ranch we were
able to pay off all of our debts except
for our house
but now our question is we still own all
of our cattle
and the cattle the money the cattle have
brought in
has overtaken what my husband makes at
his day job so his question is
should he continue on with his day job
or should we just do
ranching full time why did you quit
ranching well
we continued to ranch we just sold the
piece of property
so we just moved our animals to a closer
location
why why'd you quit why'd you sell it
because we had a huge payment that was
getting really hard to make every year
with the cattle market
[Music]
well i mean if you want to be in the
cattle business
you're in the cattle business and you
can make money doing that i don't have
any problem with that if that's true
if that's his career and direction he
wants to go have at it
that's not a problem at all for me um
the thing is i don't want you to make a
decision to walk away from the quote day
job
based on i don't know what cattle prices
are doing are they unusually high right
now
they are right now but like last year
for example um
we've always steadily been around 40
between 40 and 60
000 a year with our couch and his day
job right now he only makes about 32
000 a year yeah so i don't want you to
say we're going to make this decision
based on prices that are
unusually high that aren't going to stay
high because that would be
that'd be a false set of information
agreed
right yes sir yeah so it but if you
think that the the normal
variation in cal and uh beef prices and
i don't know what that is i'm not an
expert on that
but if you look at this and say as a
business uh this is not a
you know one of these things where the
supply chain's gotten screwed up and
beef has gone through the roof and i
thought it had i thought i heard it it
was really really expensive right now
yeah
but don't don't make your decision based
on those numbers because they're not
going to stay that way
right yeah we understand that okay if
you can make the decision going the
other way i'm not sure why you didn't do
this in the first place do you have a
day job when you sold the cattle ranch
yes he's always had a day job and he's
always done this on the side i think
he's just nervous about leaving the
stability of having
a steady paycheck yeah well i mean it
sounds like it's fairly steady at
forty or fifty thousand but not at a
hundred thousand
right okay that's what you're telling me
so i mean a steady paycheck has to do
with the quality of the business
is the business steady is the business
going to continue
and um you know an unsteady paycheck
that averages
uh 60 000 a year versus a steady
paycheck that makes 32
000 is a really really good move
a really good move so yeah don't don't
be
confused about what um where stability
comes from stability comes from his
ability to earn
in the marketplace and that he can do
that as working in cattle or you can do
that working in something else
kimberly is with us in philadelphia hi
kimberly welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my question dave is i have a pfp
account that i contribute to and i've
been
i've been contributing to the
traditional for like
24 years and also
in the g fund the whole time not knowing
any better i know now
so um i wanted to know now that i'm over
50
is it too late to switch over to raw
because i'm missing out on the
compounding no no
it does not affect the compounding at
all just to be in roth or not to be in
roth the only question is is whether the
pre-tax is better than the tax free and
tax-free is still better
um because here's the thing when you
don't switch your other
just switch your future contributions
not the not the whole account
if you flop the whole account over to
roth you're going to pay taxes on it
i just did it well i didn't
well i just i didn't i did the
allocation change
okay i'm talking about the all the money
that's in the account what's the tsp
worth
today 250 250 you didn't flop that to
roth did you
no it's it's tsp i'm sorry the tsp has a
roth option
yes i just i just i just allocated
everything i just switched um
what i did was i kept five percent i was
doing 32
for traditional i kept five percent
kimberly stopped because kimberly
stopped okay
you're talking about your contributions
now
we're not talking about your
contributions going forward
we can even switch the 250 into how it's
allocated into the
c plan the s and the i that's a
different discussion than roth
there's two different discussions
discussion number one is roth versus
traditional
discussion number two is the allocation
of c
s and i we're going to allocate the
whole thing
your future contributions and your
current account
to 80 c 10 s 10
i okay right now that's the
contributions and the existing account
the future contributions need to be roth
the 250 000 does not
okay i'll change it back i already
changed it two days ago but it's not
going to come out of my pay until the
20th
the date honey the 250 doesn't come out
of your pay
the 250 is already there you're still
not understanding me
no sorry that's okay your future
contributions that
come out of your pay when you put money
into the tsp
from today forward should
be roth that's you
the existing the old contributions that
are in there the 250 000
should remain traditional
otherwise you're going to pay taxes on
250 000 freaking dollars
don't do that okay leave that alone
that's that's the difference that's what
you've got to work through there hey
good call
thank you for calling in that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books our
thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener
i'm dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus kelly associate producer and phone
screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
[Music]
story
you